the man who don't know fee who doesn't
know the name Davy Crockett one the most
famous frontiersman of all time
Beck when Disney was pretty much king of
the world they released a show called
Davy Crockett king of the wild frontier
and after the show wrapped up they
decided to put a lot of the episodes
together into one big compilation being
this movie so yeah this is a bit of a
cheat but at the same time I think it
works okay as a film so I think if we're
talking about
and besides Davy Crockett has definitely
played a large part in Disney's identity
so I think we got to talk about it the
film like I said is a condensed version
of all the episodes so they definitely
had to cut a lot of things out this is
funny seeing how the show was already a
very romanticized version of a real
historical character so the movie sort
of serves as a best of the show but it
so comes off pretty effective seeing how
they know just how much character to
keep it there and just how many plot
points to keep in there so it never
feels rushed or out of place it's just
following his journeys of Davy his
partner Russell finding adventures to
partake in helping piece out ties with
the Native Americans and the white man
killing wildlife and occasionally even
seen the misses and his kids yeah he
does that
what once in the movie ah the 40s when
family for a man was more of a side
project with that said they don't always
shy away from the hard truths for
example the last episode and the last
part of the movie is the Alamo and well
they lose as you know happens in history
man they don't shy away from that but
again it's very romanticized everything
is played up almost more like a legend
than it is actual history even the guy
who plays Davy Fez Parker just look at
him with the squinty eyes chiseled jaw
good looks very laid back voice I mean
this guy is practically a frontiersman
Jesus and I think that's the attitude
you have to have going into this that is
romanticize it is played of it is having
fun more with the legend aspect than the
historical aspect he'll there's actually
a scene where he's talking about
grinning down a bear yeah that's right
taking down a bear by just grin
got it there's nothing so absolutely
unresisted an old-fashioned good-natured
grin like this I figured the same thing
ought to work on bars but I never got a
chance to find out it's pretty silly but
I think fess Parkers performance is so
laid-back and so confident that I kind
of enjoy it I can see how all of history
boss will look at this and kind of laugh
but I think they make the myth that they
create here just so likable that's hard
for me not to have fun with it
Russell is a good side character there's
a lot of good friends and foes that they
come across along the way some of them
stereotypes but not as mean as you would
think it just sort has its own strange
unique charm to it it is cheesy a lot of
it is kind of fictional wise but at the
same time it's the kind of story you
want to believe and you have fun
believing even though you know it's
probably not true it's like 300 you know
it's overdone but it's kind of enjoyable
how overdone it is I think that's
probably a good way to figure out
whether or not you'll enjoy it if you
want to see the true story of Davy
Crockett and his adventures this
probably isn't the best version to watch
but if you want to know about the myth
the legends or the tales that people
would tell around a campfire then you
would find out of a history book then I
say this is a lot of fun I know it's
hokey but for me it's just an
old-fashioned good time
you